Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so Daenerys Targaryen
has a whole lot in common with her predecessor
Aegon the conqueror.
They both had three dragons they're both getting
ready to conquer westeros.
So I'm going to explain the history of Aegon
before he conquered the seven kingdoms and
how that went down there is a new round of
the game of thrones giveaway going on now.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be sure
to click that bell to enable alerts so you
don't miss out on anything.
So the story.
They on the conqueror in Daenerys Targaryen
actually starts before the Doom of Valyria
Daenerys's predecessor Dan is the dreamer
from who.
Her name flows who had a vision of the Doom
of Valyria about 12 years before it happened.
So the head of the Targaryen household.
At that time radar Targaryen took his family
all of their holdings all of their dragons
everything and migrated to a valyrian outpost
that was Dragon stone and made their home.
There, so 12 years later the Doom of Valyria
happen and within about six generations Aegon
was born is a being about 87 years after the
Doom of Valyria.
So during that time after the Doom of Valyria
and during Aegon's early childhood.
There was this giant power vacuum left by
the fall of the valyrian freehold so there
were constant wars people vying for power
the rise of the free cities places like slavers
Bay as a child Aegon was watching this all
happen so the only real conflict that he got
involved in in the East before he conquered
west roast was as the Lantus was trying to
expand its territory of Lantus here was attacking
tyro's and pintos trying to expand Aegon Road
Balerion the black dread in support of Pentos
entire roast and basically burn the opposing
forces fleet before he could attack just like
Daenerys this past season in episode nine
earned the great masters fleet before he could
finish laying siege to Marine so that war
with Volantis was the last major conflict
that Aegon got involved in in the East before
the conqueror of west roast after that he
lost complete interest in the East.
So in the years before the conquest is Aegon
was growing up he visited west roast a number
of times with his sisters.
He visited Oldtown he visited Lantus port
he was guest of some of the other lords.
So he spent a lot of time in the kingdom he
commissioned the great table carved in the
shape of west roast like a giant map table
that you saw on the first couple seasons of
the TV show he commissioned that long before
the conquest of the seven kingdoms.
So at the time just like was happening in
the East, just constant wars people vying
for power, the same thing was happening in
west roast the Starks rule the North.
The gardeners not the Tyrell's ruled the reach
that actually happen after the war of conquest,
so we'll talk about that in the second house
Aaron still ruled the veil the Martell's still
rule down and Dorne here in the river lands
and here in the storm Lance there were two
lords named Aaron whore cold here in the black
and are galactic the arrogant they were to
the most belligerent petty kings at the time
and west roast inherent whore of Harrenhal
was pushing down into the storm land stealing
territory from our galactic.
So are galactic in fear reached out to Aegon
the conqueror and said please support us,
help us get rid of Heron whore all promise
you the hand of marriage to my daughter because
Aegon was already married to his two sisters
in order to cement the alliance.
He offered the hand of his closest friend
and Bastard half-brother Orys Baratheon and
so if you guys didn't know he was the first
of the house of breath and it was formed during
the conquest but yours was sort of the Jon
snow the family at the time he was a Targaryen
Bastard.
So he was Aegon's half-brother so he still
had noble blood in him are galactic cut off
the hands of Aegon's envoy, just completely
offended by the idea that his daughter would
marry a Bastard instead of marrying Aegon
himself so Aegon countered back that as part
of the dowry he would have to give up a bunch
of his land in what is now the crown lands
basically like a buffer between the storm
Lance in between the river lands in the territory
that Heron whore controlled.
So are galactic, feeling very weak wanted
to create this Targaryen buffer between him
and Heron whore.
So after our galactic rejected Aegon's offer
of Orys Baratheon and's marriage to cement
the alliance and sent the envoys hands back
in a box seven days after deliberating on
the matter Aegon sent ravens to all of the
kings of west roast in the message read from
this day forth they would be but one King
of west roast those who been the need to Aegon
of house Targaryen would keep their lands
and titles.
Those who took up arms against them would
be thrown down, humbled and destroyed, so
a lot of you know that the iron throne is
made from the melted swords of the people
who did not bend the need to Aegon the cocker
so like the Starks for instance bend the knee.
Meaning that their blades were not melted
down in the iron throne.
In this is a picture of the actual iron throne
is, it's meant to be not the one on the TV
show so it wasn't like he just melted down
the swords of the fallen lords.
It was like the Lord's and all the people
under him there were thousands of swords that
were melted down to make this solo people
is wonder are there valyrian sores that were
melted down there in the iron throne know
that is not the case valyrian swords of that
time were extremely rare, extremely precious
just like they are today.
There more scarce today but at that time they
were still pretty rare.
So most of those are just regular steel swords,
but what happened is is that initially during
the conquest Aegon did not have the most massive
army he gained support over time.
At the time of the conquest.
There were seven kings of west roast seven
kingdoms get the idea Torrhen Stark in the
North.
Ronnel Arryn in the veil Harren Hoare in the
river lands Loren Lannister in the Westerlands
Meryn Gardner King of the reach Argilac King
of the storm Lance and Mariam Martell an 80-year-old
woman who was ruling Dorne at the time so
of those seven kings you notice that there
are three houses that aren't around anymore
house whore house Durand an in-house Gardner
one of the first houses to fall was Harrenhal.
They called the burning of Harrenhal which
is why the stone looks all melted, there was
a scene with Arya during season two I think
where they get taken to the Lannister control
Harrenhal Gendry Hot pie wonder why the stones
look all melted and Arya replies dragons codify
mouse strike in darkness that Cisco, so the
story of Harrenhal itself the castle is pretty
ridiculous.
It was meant to be this giant monstrosity
to tower over all other castles to show everyone
that Heron whore was the most mighty king
in west roast.
So of course in spectacular fashion Aegon
melted most of the towers.
So it still exists because we visited it during
the first couple of seasons on the show that
there after it was said that the place was
cursed in each new Lord to hold the castle
met an untimely end just terrible things would
happen there, so you never want to be gifted
with Harrenhal is always a great thing when
the king gives you a castle Harrenhal is the
only one that you do not want after the conquest
of the river lands he moved down to the storm
Lance and Concord are galactic territory took
it for himself and gave it to Orys Baratheon
of marrying him to relax daughter creating
house Baratheon and so that was the beginning
of the Baratheon and's in the storm Lance,
so a lot of your wondering yes Gendry does
share a small amount of genetic material with
Daenerys there like very, very, very distant
cousins.
Next he conquered the Westerlands in the reach
there was a very famous encounter called the
field of fire whereby the gardeners had their
armies mast ready to fight in an open field
Aegon Road is Dragon and burn the entire field
tens of thousands of soldiers to the ground
and that was the end of house Gardner when
he then went to high garden the Tyrell's had
been stewards of the castle.
They yielded it immediately.
So Aegon named them house Tyrell lords of
the reach later the Starks Nelson submission.
So Torrhen Stark the king at the time became
known as the King who knelt he conquered the
veil and then finally Dorne was the last place
that he went, but because of the terrain and
because his army wasn't used to desert tactics
he had to withdraw.
Thus, it was really the six kingdoms that
he conquered and then many generations later
Dorne finally came into the fold, but Aegon
did not conquer Dorne, so a lot of your wondering
are they going to mirror this with Daenerys
in season seven as she goes after Cersei the
kingdom will split some like the Lannister's
like house Charlie will support the crown
others will support Daenerys at the idea of
a new Targaryen rain.
So just like when Aegon first made landfall.
In west roast and started the conquest his
army got bigger over time as he gained support
of the same thing will probably happen with
Daenerys.
So I would be surprised at Daenerys has a
couple encounters before she treats with house
stark and they form an alliance.
But then you have other houses like house
Tyrell that have already pledge their support
Taveras so it's not like Daenerys is starting
at zero she has her unsullied she has the
forces of high garden when you look at all
the faces here as Cersei is being crowned.
These are the faces of really happy lords
and ladies.
So part of great drama is in watching people
who you would think support Cersei completely
turned against her which all link my Jaime
Valenqar theory video at the end of this.
Let me know in the comments do you think that
they're going to mirror Aegon's conquest with
Daenerys and season seven plot as she marches
on the iron throne in which houses do you
think will bend the knee inside with Daenerys
if there are any other history videos that
you guys want me to do just let me know in
the comments below.
I will say congratulations to infinite mortal
geared this week's giveaway winner.
Please private message me on the back end
of my channel so I can get your contact details
and there is a new round that started with
this video just announce the winner the next
time I post a game of thrones video for next
history video might be a history of the Starks
and how they came to be wargs.
So if you guys want anything else just let
me know in the comments while you guys wait
for that to post you can click here for my
Jaime Valenqar theory video and you can click
here for my Westworld season two predictions
you so much watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight!